eigentlich wollte ich nun wochenende
hier in lodz in polen bleiben
jetzt wurde mein flug gecancelt weil
hier in polen nichts mehr geht keine
flugzeuge kommen mehr rein und deswegen
kommen auch keine mehr raus das heißt
ich komme auch nicht nach deutschland
im kampf gegen das corona virus hat sich
polen abgeschottet seit dem wochenende
steht auch lodge still
geschäfte und restaurants haben
geschlossen nur lebensmittel läden und
apotheken sind geöffnet zu verlassen wie
jetzt ist diese einkaufsstraße sonst nur
sonntags für essens lieferdienste
scheint es das geschäft zu sein denn das
geht als einziges noch zurück im hotel
versuche ich schon den ganzen tag meines
lud gesellschaft zu erreichen
nach mehr als einer stunde warteschleife
komme ich endlich durch und schaue schon
einmal nach alternativen
mein rückflug wurde jetzt um zwei wochen
nach hinten verschoben und auch ein
mietwagen der liegt bei 1000 euro lässt
sich aber nicht mal suchen weil ich ja
in deutschland abgeben würde und es
funktioniert aktuell nicht jetzt ist die
einzige chance die noch bleibt dass ich
an die grenze mit dem bus fahren und von
dort nach deutschland rüber laufe und
das will ich jetzt versuchen
der bus fährt nur einmal am tag und dann
auch noch mitten in der nacht und außer
mir scheinen das auch nicht so viele zu
machen
knapp fünf stunden brauche ich von lodz
zur deutschen grenze meine idee über die
brücke nach deutschland laufen wenn
alles klappt bin ich innerhalb weniger
minuten in frankfurt an der oder
meine navigations app gibt an dass die
straße gesperrt sei aber ich hoffe das
gilt nicht für fußgänger an der grenze
angekommen die erwarteten kontrollen
aber zum glück nur in polnische richtung
aus dem bus gestiegen bin hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass so viele leute
relativ viel um die uhrzeit über die
brücke laufen werden und man kommt doch
einfach überall kam noch laufen ohne
dass man kontrolliert wird und dann bin
ich endlich wieder in deutschland von
frankfurt an der oder geht es weiter in
richtung mainz nach zwölf stunden
abenteuerliche reise